not to be like I'm cool and you're not
it's like yo you know what's [ __ ]
cool self-awareness
[Music]
the number one gift my mom gave me is a
lack of entitlement what's really
empowering and what's holding so many
people back here is entitlement you feel
like somebody owes you something because
something went wrong somewhere along the
way I don't
I actually think whatever went wrong for
you is the best [ __ ] that ever happened
to you because that versity is
absolutely the foundation of success
nobody owes you [ __ ] first one is from
Nicholas
and there's questions how do you create
content if your life is boring and it's
a research and I'm getting a vibe he's
like a Shopify seller source it says a
lot of his work she's popping here you
know I think a lot of things are boring
man like I think I'm boring I think a
lot of things might like this is like
most of your life is just sitting at a
desk
yeah man lickings yeah like like
honestly I want to make sure you're a
part of this post right now like I'm a
[ __ ] business man like I don't know
like playing soccer is boring to some
people like painting is boring to some
people you don't get the judge for the
other person if somebody's trying to
learn how to flip and sell and if you
can just get to a place where as you're
working you're talking like right now
I'm posting this and I use this title
because the views 3 exclamation points
I've noticed that I've sold more and
[ __ ] I got to go to the post office now
and pack it it's the grind and it's the
dirt that nobody wants to talk about
it's not glamorous it's not champagne
bottles and [ __ ] models but I got to
go to the [ __ ] post office if I want
to build a foundation of my business
like to me everything is potentially
remarkable and potentially boring you
just need to document and not create and
then you got to let the world decide if
you're boring or you're not and then you
also have to Evan flow and be patient I
don't know if news alert I don't film
buddies paying attention my views on my
[ __ ] daily blog are down
year-over-year
ask me if I give a [ __ ] ask me
short-term vanity metrics means [ __ ] and
all of you are poisoned by the sizzle
behind them I've never been happier and
my boobs are down on YouTube you know
documenting next question I thought this
would be a good one
based on today is how do you plan to
grab and take advantage sort of early
mover opportunities for edgy TV you know
to me it's a it's about producing
content that's native to a platform
right the number one thing you want to
do is create content that is native to a
platform and I think right now what I'm
trying to figure out is what's native
tied GTV obviously we're doing this
entire dailyvee in IG TV format and
vertical right you know you've been
watching Batman hold the camera now is
awkward and exciting all at once and so
you know to me will that matter
it's a thesis but to me the people that
tend to win platforms are the ones that
innovate or understand the context of a
platform you either saw a platform in a
different way than everybody else did
and you changed the game and I'll be
very honest with you like one of things
that I don't think I peacock enough
about his long-form video on YouTube in
2006 nobody was doing it
I never I'd do a very bad job propping
me up on something that I innovate I was
like why can't it be long I think being
in the Y business like just asking
questions matters like you know why
can't I GTV
you know like like who's doing content
as a blogger who decides to just make
their eye GTB and animation or chord is
it just vertical will that be enough or
commercials I don't know like why can't
we just have commercials in the middle
of like right affluent but if I stop
right now it's just a commercial for the
case with so there's you got to innovate
and you got to understand that you got
to be empathetic to somebody sitting on
their phone watching it like this right
what does that mean you know like do you
do funny you remember with a spongebob
when you're saying Lancer like I know
that weird [ __ ] like maybe maybe every 7
minutes we just do something like you
know put your coffee down or like pay up
a son [ __ ] like you know like I don't
know innovation and context innovating
on a platform or respecting the context
of a platform are the two people that
always break out
then you later the talent or the
interesting thing that the person does
[Music]
really good good to see us real pleasure
good everything's super good something
how are you Gary that's me so I had
already built a business my family's
lives just for business like I'd already
like I live the life I was 34 I lived a
life before all this [ __ ] started
happening and just watching the
Entrepreneurship be put on a pedestal is
exciting and also scary I will tell you
that the number one one of the number
one fears I have is too many kids want
to be an entrepreneur even though
they're not yeah that's what's
interesting is because like I think that
entrepreneurship is having a moment and
also you're like directly out in front
of it you don't I mean like it's having
a moment and you are the top you don't
know how many people how many meetings I
go into now and everyone now has a
camera guy oh yeah and that's literally
100 percent I think influenced by what
you're doing but my question is so
obviously that's cool and that's the
discussion that a lot of people have on
this podcast is like everyone's not the
preneur now and I said I think that the
good news is there will be more real
entrepreneurs out of this wow it's gonna
be a lot of there to your point net yeah
there are thousands tens of thousands
that would argue hundreds of thousands
and maybe even millions who during this
era find entrepreneurship the freedoms
that come with it the beauty of it
that wouldn't have twenty years ago
because there would have been executives
what I'm worried about is the collateral
damage what do you think happens to the
person this caught in the crossfire I
think there's some people that commit
suicide I think there's some people that
you understand why I say that depression
because you can't hide like when your
t-shirt business fails because the
economy fails and influencers don't get
paid like that anymore
and [ __ ] hits the fan and you go work at
Citibank your family and friends know
one of the things I did really well was
I lived humble as [ __ ] I live in a
[ __ ] one-bedroom apartment
Springfield New Jersey didn't cost much
I didn't get fancy moved to New York I
never went out so really easy to like
save money when you don't spend a
thousand bucks on a weekend hitting it
hard and I saved they say they say I
didn't have a lot of money but
everything I
had I been on Facebook and Twitter when
this is why I believe people can win I
wasn't making a lot of money I was
building a business for somebody else i
I just lived humbly like everybody wants
to some kid just tweeted I put out that
tweet somebody else is like yeah other
kids like easy for you guys to say was
so much easier in the 70 80s and 90s I'm
like you're a [ __ ] loser dick we
didn't have internet the [ __ ] do you
know about the 70 80s and 90s you
[ __ ] suck [ __ ] like like it's not
easier you're just lazy and entitled cuz
mommy and daddy did everything for you
and you think life's about playing
[ __ ] Xbox and smoking weed and
[ __ ] drinking Mountain Dew you
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't work yeah thank
you my man what's your name oh yes oh
he's filming alright what's your name
mati like I'm Gary nice to meet you i
watch all our videos well thank you
thank you so much worry free shopping
energy Thank You Bella all right that
was amazing
[Music]
I know it's exciting
I'm proud of it are you done thank you
yes how are you guys dead hey Gary such
a pleasure how are you nice bill a sense
yeah yeah I mean look every of everybody
you look it's always a branding game
always life all of it religion like
college like marriage it's all [ __ ]
brandman so you know I think that you
know I grew up in a heavy regulated
business that was obviously more mature
in the fact that the rules were
established but not really rules and so
tough right right so great and was
changing and what I was doing internet
marketing internet selling was like so
gray so I know the stomach in the
athletic for the stuff that the stakes
are so high when you're right
[Music]
is that a former Samsung sign that's
like one of the reasons to like have a
sign even when it comes down it's
actually still there like the son took
care of it
[Music]